a un mes de las elecciones brasil
celebra sus 200 años de independencia
liderando un desfile militar en brasilia
el presidente y candidato a la
reelección
jair bolsonaro convino la celebración
con un acto de campaña en un ambiente de
tensión máxima arremetiendo contra las
encuestas que le dan por perdedor en los
comicios del 2 de octubre
no
[Aplausos]
aquí no tenemos mentiras de data folk ya
aquí está nuestro data pueblo aquí está
la verdad
y aquí está la voluntad de un pueblo
honesto libre y trabajador luego de
estar en prisión durante 18 meses por un
caso de corrupción
lula volvió al escenario político hace
más de un año los sondeos más recientes
le dan un 44 por ciento de la intención
de voto 10 puntos porcentuales por
encima de bolsonaro el izquierdista
también se lleva la ventaja en una
eventual segunda vuelta
gasolina comida todo estar on bolsonaro
genocida pero no todos los actos del 7
de septiembre fueron el apoyo a
versionar yo durante los últimos 28 años
miles de brasileros se unen a las ya
tradicionales manifestaciones del grito
de los excluidos y este año los
contradictores del mandatario brasilero
se unieron a las marchas acusando al
líder de extrema derecha de usar la
fiesta nacional para su campaña de
reelección
esta manifestación es fundamental ya que
el presidente bolsonaro junto a
congresistas moderados y militares
amenaza con un golpe de estado en
nuestro país eliminando todos los
derechos de los trabajadores
los seguidores de evolucionario también
se tomaron las playas de copacabana en
río de janeiro expresaron su apoyo a un
líder que ha sembrado dudas de manera
reiterada en la confiabilidad del
sistema de voto electrónico en brásil
dejando en el aire la posibilidad de que
rechace los resultados si lula lo
derrota en las urnas